what's up guys and welcome to Horus
hobbies where we discussed the hottest
tech news and of into newest tech
products today we're taking a look at
why mining will soon be relevant to
gamers and see what the a6 craze all
about but before we begin make sure hit
that subscribe button if you want to be
updated with the latest tech news
related to PCs and gaming so guys as you
guys may have already noticed GPU
practice have been dropping in price
recently and while Nvidia did raise the
supply last month I strongly believe
that the main cause for these drop in
prices is actually decreased demand from
minors for these graphics cards this is
due to the constantly decreasing price
of cryptocurrency and consistently
increasing difficulty of mining
cryptocurrency why is the difficulty to
mind cryptocurrency getting harder well
there is a limited amount of
cryptocurrency and at once that all runs
out there will be nothing to mine for
example there's only 21 million bitcoins
available and there are 84 million
litecoins and so on and so forth and
every day more and more of these
cryptocurrencies are being mined thus
everyday there's less cryptocurrency
available to be mind and therefore is
getting harder and harder every day to
mine these cryptocurrencies and
unfortunately for miners the difficulty
has been rapidly increasing due to the
influx of miners onto the scene for
example many cryptocurrencies have
doubled in difficulty in just the last
few months like aetherium and Bitcoin
and this is just the beginning of the
issues there is much bigger issues
lurking just around the corner
cryptocurrencies have been going down
and valued quite consistently and since
it is a relatively new type of currency
it is hard to predict what it is going
to do next
plus the value of cryptocurrency is
heavily dependent on how much people are
interested in it and so that makes it
even more fluctuate Abel it's not even
worried well it makes it more prone to
change these circumstances have probably
deterred more people who are looking to
get into cryptocurrency mining to
rethink their
decisions or completely abandon the idea
altogether these situations are probably
not favorable for seasoned miners either
because this does bring up some debate
whether they should or shouldn't buy a
new mining setup or expand their
existing one no matter how knowledgeable
one is it is always difficult to invest
into something that it has been
consistently going down and it is
unknown when and if it would even rise
at all so as it is evident the mining
scene is not doing very well and its
impact can clearly be seen in graphics
card prices as a result GPUs across the
board have drastically dropped in price
recently or they're consistently
dropping at the very least so what my
name is experiencing a downfall right
now and that is causing a dip in
graphics card prices that doesn't mean
mining itself is irrelevant the gaming
GPUs ever my Mii could shoot back at any
time
normally that would be true but recent
hype around a Baikal's new ASIC may
actually be warranted because it is
supposedly going to bring much superior
mining performance when compared to
gaming graphics cards I know that ASIC
computers won't have the same resale
value as a gaming GPU but if this
machine brings with it much superior
performance at a much lower TDP like it
is set to bring then it would most
certainly be enticing for miners so what
exactly is this new ASIC and why is it
important well this new ASIC is
essentially used to mine cryptocurrency
using their crypto and an algorithm
which could be used to mine things like
Manero wait but what exactly is an ASIC
computer in the first place well ASIC
stands for application specific
integrated circuit and it is built for a
specific purpose after miners their ASIC
computers of are built purely in the
intent of mining using a specific
algorithm - specific cryptocurrency so
unfortunately these machines do limit
our miners options for mining but -
mainly focus on ROI or return on
investment and as long as that is
satisfactory for them and why would they
buy these so what is so cool about these
new mining machines and why is it
different
other Asics well this new mining machine
is from the company by called China and
here's what's crazy about it it can
supposedly mine coins that utilize a
kryptonite algorithm at a hash rate of
20 kilohertz per second and it's TDP is
only 60 watts these are absolutely
insane specs and can provide crazy good
returns while this is horrible news to
existing Kryptonite miners could invest
a lot into graphics cards this may be
what many miles of other
cryptocurrencies or new miners decide to
invest in and of course this will
definitely take away unlock demand for
graphics cards for the purpose of mining
so as you guys can see this new ASIC and
new Asics in the future could save
graphics card from mining once and for
all
overall mining is getting quite
difficult to sustain due to the
increased difficulty to mana
cryptocurrencies across the board and
dropping prices at bears crypto
currencies isn't helping the situation
either on top of this there is a much
superior option coming for a certain -
which will also determiners from buying
gaming graphics cards as a result the
demand for gaming GPUs from miners has
been decreasing for a while now and a
big drop and demand is coming up soon
based on current circumstances and
ultimately because of all this GPU
mining should hopefully be irrelevant to
gamers from now on but that is pretty
much all I have for you guys this time
make sure to post what you guys are
thinking in the comment down below for
example do you guys think this is just a
little dip in mining do you think my
name is dead for good or do you think
it'll make it to Butte later on in 2019
or even after that I read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts but definitely not for you guys
this time make sure to drop a like on
this video if you guys enjoyed it and
subscribe if you would like to see more
videos just like this but until next
time bye
[Music]